doc werden präsentiert von honda jazz
[Musik]
die retter kommen vom himmel
jeder verstanden
15.000 einsätze pro jahr auch für
menschen in not
[Musik]
im sekt und helikopter
im in und ausland das ist die rega
[Musik]
arbeitsbeginn beim team von reger 10 in
wilderswil
das sind rettungssanitäter markus artz
tommy von will und pilot rigmor er
kontrolliert wie jeden morgen seine
maschine die logik des stroms ist der
beste ist so dass jede pause sie helle
also wirklich drum 'n' bass gitarre und
angriff der am 12
das ist es auch wieder eine wegnahme und
ich finde das sogar
zudem helle dass israel das ist stärker
da das kennzeichen r t wird im flieger
alphabets romeo tango
lange wird reger 10 nicht am boden
bleiben es ist der erste schöne
frühlingstage am flughafen zürich in der
zentrale der regel sind die ambulanzjets
stationiert und hier werden auch alle
helikopter der 13 rega blasen
koordiniert einsatzleiterin gtq tritt
den dienst an auf welchen gletscher sind
sie ein gletscher und auf welcher höhe
das knie ist eine landung möglich
regelsatz steigt oder knieverletzung
gleichschritt
jeder handgriff sitzt in fünf minuten
muss roman tango in der luft sein
[Musik]
wir werden den helikopter schicken wird
dann gleitet maschine laufen
[Musik]
nicht schlecht
derstandard.at sind unterwegs richtig
steinbrecher länderseite möglicher 74
sekunden entschied der signal in unseren
gesellschaften verlassen
herrlich wie peter stein steht dort
stahl er in der luft prüft die crew die
genauen koordinaten des unfallautos
übermittelt vom rega center
[Musik]
und wenn er was ihn stört
ich glaube hier vorbeifahren
[Musik]
wenn ich nach europa geleitet
eine landung beim verunfallten
skitourenfahrer ist unmöglich
arzt und rettungssanitäter steigen aus
dem schwebenden helikopter
pilot rick maurer fliegt in
startposition
ich habe das knie verdreht und kann
nicht mehr aufstehen bewegen nicht
richtig ich kann das knie nicht mehr
bieten sonst hast du keine verletzung
hast du allergie nein das ist kein
schmerzmittel
es ist sehr stark
rettungssanitäter marke steigt wieder in
den helikopter um die winter zu bedienen
[Musik]
es wird ziemlich gelassen nachher
wir werden uns nicht mehr verstehen
laut geschwinde medien
der pilot während der winden rettung
keinen sichtkontakt zu patient und arzt
er muss sich ganz auf die angaben von
marco lehmann der winter verlassen
[Musik]
sieht einfach aus ist es nicht diese
präzision erfordert viel training und
erfahrung
[Musik]
ein paar hundert meter weiter unten
landet der rallye und die crew ley den
patienten ein
[Musik]
ich habe mit geografischer
informationssysteme gesehen jetzt sicher
genug gespielt
interlaken ist das heim spital von
regazzoni
hier landet roman tango oft mehrmals pro
tag
wir brauchen
[Applaus]
um den er jetzt im ziemlich sofort
schmerzen gehabt
panik
und schon ist reger 10 wieder in der
luft bereit für einen neuen fall
[Musik]
den takt gibt die einsatzzentrale
helikopter in zürich vor rund um die uhr
geht die crew leitet ein team von 20
mitarbeitern die jedes jahr mehr als
11.000 einsätze koordinieren
die kinder kommen gleich neben der
einsatzzentrale helikopter werden die
einsätze der drei ambulanzjets
koordiniert draußen vor dem rega center
trifft jetpilot philips siemens in athen
es so ganz früheren baby wie oft wo ich
für 236 schwangerschaftswoche obama
verändert emotional gut mitfühlen mit
älteren aus dem momentan programm
zum gleichen team gehört auch
pflegefachfrau egon horisberger sie
wurde am vorabend für diesen einsatz
aufgeboten geholl es ist knapp ein kilo
800 nicht so viel haben wir die energie
bringe das winzige baby braucht einen
100 kilo schweren brutkasten pilot
philipp sémon pakt mit seinem co piloten
an
7 arbeitet seit zwölf jahren für die
rega schon bald soll er zum kapitän
befördert werden alle arbeiten hand in
hand zusammen mit dem arzt bauen die
piloten den brutkasten 1
pflegefachfrau yvonne horisberger kann
für diesen flug auf die hilfe einer
kollegin aus dem kinderspital zürich
zählen die letzten vorbereitungen und
sakrament war im kühlschrank müsse sie
kaum erwarten rabatte geld die erfahrene
intensiv pflegefachfrau ist auch für die
verpflegung im chat zuständig eine
allrounderin der abflug steht kurz bevor
die einsatzzentrale jet hat die reise
minutiös vorbereitet und ruft zum
schluss briefing musik und hat auch
gerade ihr werdet abgeholt am flughafen
gefunden ambulanz das ist es was das ist
bis medizinisches an die band no zum
operationellen
philipp simmen wird nicht nur vom co
piloten sondern auch von einem
instruktor begleitet seine beförderung
zum captain steht kurz bevor
er steht unter beobachtung
[Musik]
noch ist die rolle auf der linken
cockpit seite neu für ihn
[Musik]
verantwortlich für die organisation im
bereich noch stimmig in europa
das positiv so strahlend wie es dann
gottes auf kuba und entsprachen
ich stehe mit einer gut 50 uhr werden
forderte der pauli bereitet mit dem
gewürz das machen so mitkriege
rechtzeitig etwas auch in hochstimmung
[Musik]
rege chef pilot os nagel hat auf dem job
sieht platz genommen
er bildet philip simon zum flugkapitän
aus
nein aber wenn du hast die wahl
start richtung athen
in der einsatzzentrale helikopter trifft
ein neuer notrufe verletzt verletzt eine
musikalische mich unverletzt
riga 10 macht sich auf den weg richtung
erlenbach im simmental
[Musik]
genaue koordinaten fehlen es ist eine
suche aus der luft eine erfolgreiche
suche
für arzt tommy von wil ist schnell klar
es wird ein kampf ums leben
[Musik]
ich habe vor und 52 meter steil
spielerisch entdecken zum schluss
notierten ak7 so lautet der medizinische
code für einen todesfall alltag für die
crew von riga 10
aber keine routine jetzt aus dem lager
kritisiert wenn schlimmes passiert
sondern immer nur also mich zumindest im
moment wenn man offen ich den kommunen
art abschalten und sich auf das
wesentliche fokussieren
april wenn es wenn sie für die stehen
tut man sich schon gedanken machen
[Musik]
die nachricht von abba 7 in erlenbach
lässt auch die kuh nicht kalt und dann
dank stark sie sind jetzt richtig
gemacht und ist gott gemacht attraktives
rennen besser machen und das ist einfach
so dass in ihrem zehn ihr tod aber
darauf dass sich mancher etwas schönes
leben verändert und sich aqua dann hat
das kind bank darstellt
der rega ambulanzjet ist mittlerweile
hoch über den wolken auf der reise nach
athen
pilot philipp sémon hat kaum zeit zum
essen
der instruktor nimmt ihn in beschlag die
pisten zahl in thessaloniki ist nur eine
von vielen wissensfragen die
medizinische crew bespricht die details
der repatriierung
herr stunde korte zustand ist da
geschrieben für das android 2.3 sie die
affären risikoschwangerschaft und
dazwischen sind sich kreislauf ist
stabil
müssen sie trinkt anscheinend alles
selber vielleicht neues horisberger ist
in ihrem element
etwa 70 tage pro jahr verbringt sie in
der luft
ende
bernburg bewegt statistischen auf sie
bezogen wo wir selber ihn verraten dass
putin bei einem besuch in athen arbeiten
wird der raum blond ist dass nicht mehr
alle haben auf den form zu kommen das
handling von roth wird sich darum
kümmern dass sie euch zudem einbringen
kommt der russische präsident putin der
erreger und baby jury in die quere
[Musik]
reger 10 ist zurück auf der basis in
wilderswil um neues medizinisches
material zu holen und zu tanken
eine tankfüllung reicht für etwa eine
stunde und 20 minuten flugzeit tankwart
ist rettungssanitäter marcolli
gps auch als bindeglied zwischen medizin
und flüge viele kleine bei die bereiche
neuigkeit vom eigentlich schon mal das
zimmer war so je nach entscheidung was
ich jetzt mal eine richtige die
pflegerische sieht hatte die
medizinische jedes crewmitglied hat
seine aufgaben
ich hoffe die größe des abzugs der basis
und meistens auch hier meist zum kuchen
zu machen und das ist sein wird sondern
ich hoffe nicht denn eigentlich hat
damit bis budapest zur seite gestellt
die nicht nur noch zwölf stunden wehre
mich und clubs deshalb ist die
improvisation in polen gleich aber das
ist okay
rick maurer hat sich in der büro
arbeiten gemacht
er ist nicht nur pilot sondern auch
leiter der basis mit zwölf mitarbeitern
immer auch einfach scheint jahren mit
der angestellte hier qualifikation muss
oder dass das ist einfach obwohl oft
werden oder wenn jetzt einfach dass und
das macht also 250 patienten ist noch
eine parallele zum pikett instabilität
natürlich trägt 20 sekunden
[Musik]
der rega jet ist in athen gelandet
die zeit drängt noch sind die chancen
offen
die ambulanz konnte vorfahren aber
irgendwann wird es wegen präsident
putins besuch kein durchkommen mehr
geben
[Applaus]
lokalität und während andere stunde um
zwei stunden auch eine fenstergröße
straßensperre planer sachen dies nachdem
herr begreifen welchen später auch zum
flughafen
jetzt will man sorge dass man diesen
fahrplan liebe besseren aber immer recht
schnell auch ein trick übergaben spital
machen
der verkehr in athen hat es auch ohne
sperren in sich aber schließlich trifft
die ambulanz im mathias spital und bei
den eltern von julie ein jeder mit
gerechnet dass sie ihre leute
damit diese so wie ich auch so
juni und vom selben tag gemacht aber
holen
ja also ich sage hier
doch ich mich schon
[Musik]
vor 13 tagen ist juli zur welt gekommen
die eltern durften sie bisher nur zwei
mal pro tag eine halbe stunde lang sehen
und sind überglücklich dass sie ihr baby
endlich in die schweiz nehmen dürfen
[Musik]
der zweite vorname von geely ist athene
als erinnerung an den abenteuerlichen
start ins leben
[Musik]
trotz der eile
vor dem aufbruch will der rega arzt
genau wissen wie es geht
[Musik]
also startete kritik doch gott direkt
herzens zur traurigen ganz gut geht und
dort überall und welche was mache ich
falsch gemacht sie nicht jetzt und jetzt
genau zwei minuten
geld kam es nach
auf keinen fall möchte rogers kam mit
juli im verkehr blockiert werden
und tatsächlich haben juli und das
regieteam glück sie kommen ohne
verzögerung zum flughafen
wladimir putin ist noch nicht
eingetroffen
ok
strom abgestellt
billig brauchst dann auch ein hacker
aber finger hebe aber da steht keiner so
genau
[Musik]
im rega center in zürich ist der
ereignisreiche tag noch nicht
abgeschlossen
[Musik]
der hausberg von interlaken befindet
sich gleich gegenüber der basis ein
kurzer flug jetzt verbinde mit dem
helikopter und 20 im sack ja ich liebe
sie am telefon ich verbinde
aber ja logisch aber traut ist da diese
binder sich aufgeregt ich war die
[Musik]
verbindet sich ein jetzt mit dem rauchen
jetzt für diese personengruppe
erkennbare sportwagen durch die kunden
vertrauen missbraucht ich glaube er weiß
wo ja ganz sicher ich liebe es mit dem
telefon bis der drb innern ist nicht das
geschieht in görlitz wo ist er endlich
da ist noch nie in einen wanderweg dass
sich bewusst sie sie berührte fertig
haben kopf tut immer versperrt und das
sind genau gesagt das 15
im rega ambulanzjet verschläft juli
athene ihren ersten flug
soll ich dir
genau
[Musik]
philips siemens letzter einsatz vor der
beförderung zum kapitän geht zu ende
der sinkflug nach bern
die ambulanz wird juli ins inselspital
bringen
[Musik]
sohn louis den die großmutter in athen
abgeholt hat steht zum empfang bereit
[Musik]
zusammen
am harder in internaten lässt sich arzt
tommy von wil an einer 60 meter winter
absetzen
bord haben
jetzt geht er zu fuß zur frau die vom
wanderweg ein paar meter abgestürzt ist
jobact sich gut biene bis in dieser
krieg a30 da super super dann heraus
untergrund ruhe und dräger zeit
verstanden
wer ganz einverstanden
ich bin patient ich als mieter vor wild
hatte tochter von der patientin am
telefon begleitet bis trotz des sich der
heli ist zwischengelandet pilot rick
mora steht in kontakt mit dem arzt am
unfallort
jetzt geht es darum arzt und patientin
sicher aus dem wald zu bringen
der abwind des helikopters der
sogenannte downloads darf auf keinen
fall erste abreißen
freundlich
oder holen sondern unsere strategie war
stunden die wie dringt auf das rechts
durch sprechen und musizieren die
discounter die wiederum an den schweden
ach so
was ich machen soll
[Musik]
apa
ich darf
wo ist
für rettungssanitäter marco ley und
pilot ringmauer ist die mission zu ende
[Musik]
und auch geht die kuhns schließt den
fall erleichtert ab wenn ich mir ein
bisschen noch mit cs beschäftigt oder
virtuelles kind welches der film dann
mit dem bringt dich selber bereit
mannschaft lästigen sieben jahre
erfahrung helfen die kuhns ruhe zu
bewahren spital interlaken nach der
wenigen rettung von vortrag ist tommy
von viel unterwegs zur patientin die am
harder abgestürzt ist er kennt die
abteilungen bestens neben seinem job bei
der regler arbeitet von will hier als
leitender arzt steht besser wurde das
grand casino habe und die stadt kremmen
also die starken an der küste muss mit
apple und den hat probiert mit
schutzweste schuss kommt ist nicht
bekannt
und wenn die mieter darüber lustig sie
nein sagen wenn ich eine bessere figur
ab
die patientin wird noch lange unter dem
unfall leuten neben dem schädel hirn
trauma macht hier eine knieverletzung
noch viele wochen zu schaffen
rega center zürich
im herbst stellen bietet flexstrom würde
das team für bücher und das sehr
oberflächlich laufbewegung intensiv
pflegefachfrau yvonne hobelsberger und
kathi cortez fliegen heute nach italien
die j crew wird einem patienten abholen
der nach einem verkehrsunfall schwer
verletzt im spital liegt zu früh um aus
dem magen schießen flogen
im cockpit nimmt philipp sémon zum
ersten mal als frisch frittierter
flugkapitän platz er hat die prüfungen
hinter sich
die fluglehrer und dasselbe freund
ich sage jetzt mal belastet haben ein
mehr über twitter birgt wird und sie das
kommando punkt korrigiert wird
das nötig ist das nimmt der folge und
sind marcel schäfer
[Musik]
hochbetrieb in der einsatzzentrale
helikopter
ein einsatz im napfgebiet pilot rick
maurer und seine crew sind in wenigen
minuten startklar
[Musik]
noch wissen sie nicht was sie erwartet
auch einsatzleiterinnen gt kuhn kennt
die einzelheiten noch nicht nachhaltig
sind beide bewusstlos im neckar
vermutlich sind mutter und tochter wegen
gülle gas ohnmächtig geworden weil im
rega helikopter nummer eine person
liegen transportiert werden kann hat die
zentrale in diesem fall zwei maschinen
aufgeboten
[Musik]
reger 3 ist schon vor ort und schnell
wird klar dass bei der ärzte gefordert
sind mutter und kind werden sofort
künstlich beatmet es ist unklar wie
lange die patientinnen bewusstlos im
stadtladen und die giftigen dämpfe
eingeatmet haben die tochter ist schon
bereit für den abflug
aber noch muss für beide patientinnen
ein spitalbett organisiert werden
inzwischen nimmt das team von regel
ziehen die bewusstlose mutter an bord
platz für bier trinkt gott nicht gläubig
luft ok ok oder mit beidem
[Musik]
foto rpo
moskau
[Musik]
inselspital bern hier werden mutter und
tochter versorgt
eigentlich untersagen richten sie halten
passanten ich sage jetzt müssten jetzt
bringen wir es einfach eigentlich die
zentrale magazin zurück in wilderswil
notarzt romy von will hat die
patientinnen spezialisten übergeben
das gab frauen darum dass leute wie sie
jetzt ein neurologisches das heißt von
ropa dass das ganze bestand worum es da
auch intensiv station uhr ab gegenüber
und den etwas macht man sie lachen und
hofft dass sie dass sie das mit cannes
oder michael streng ich sag mal jeden
schaden und bestimmt später wird romy
von widerfahren mutter und tochter lagen
noch tagelang im spital
sie haben den unfall aber ohne bleibende
schäden überstanden
die crew des ambulanzjets ist unterwegs
in ein italienisches spital
sie holt einen patienten ab der bei
einem verkehrsunfall schwer verletzt
wurde
wir müssen auf die intensivstation
die ambulanz fahrer scheinen um sicher
es herrscht verwirrung
ich weiß nicht ob es im dritten stock
eine intensivstation hat sie können da
vorne fragen immer noch funde
hinten links erster stock wir kommen aus
der schweiz
wir holen den schweizer patient
vielleicht sind sie auf der falschen
intensivstation
es ist ein schwer verletzter patient sie
ihren sich er ist nicht hier
die rega ist im auftrag einer
versicherung unterwegs und die hat die
adresse der klinik falsch angegeben rega
center in zürich
ein notruf vom niesen
das ist okay jetzt sie sind aber
unverletzt das ist richtig hat des fells
um sie herum und sie waren auf dem
wanderweg ich habe eine idee wo sie sein
könnten war es so ein zickzack wanderweg
den sichern unter gehen wollten
das war dann kein weg ich glaube ich
weiß wo sie sind hatte ich glaube ich
weiß was sie sind
das team von reger 10 macht sich mit
romeo tango auf zur rettung
die crew des riga jets ist immer noch
auf der suche nach der patienten neue
klinik zweiter versuch
doch ich bin von der rega zwei meter
hoher ist berührend schweiz zurück flüge
mit instituts zurück bringen er sich
schon schlafen während dem ganzen flug
haben sie das verstanden sowie die
gewürze
der patient ist nach einem
verkehrsunfall schwer verletzt an becken
brustkorb und lunge
[Musik]
mein name ist ivan horisberger spiel
vorbei schauen was gut zum laden noch im
flug
[Musik]
das team von reger 10 sucht am niesen
den wanderer der sich verirrt hat mit an
bord ist ein gebirgsspezialisten alpinen
rettung schweiz einer
partnerorganisation der rega
ich möchte in diesem abschüssigen
gelände würde denn der schöpfung
wanderer auf die bergung vorbereiten
[Applaus]
der mann ist unverletzt präventiv
einsätze nennt die rega solche fälle
heute lebt doch
weiter unten wird er allein seinen
heimweg antreten
die kosten sind gedeckt er ist reger
gönner wir erleben die retter einsätze
für freizeitsportler die sich
leichtfertig in gefahr bringen
acht leute die einfach gut
die geschlechter madrid wieder die
einfachen und realitätsnah der 14 14 mal
und der comedian und das war spekuliert
dass kubica wieder funktionieren möchte
juni grundsätzlich meinen ärger den man
einfach zutritt zum helle und grundsatz
vom roten kreuz das man eigentlich jedem
muss jeder situation probiert auf und
der kann eigentlich nach dem prinzip und
probieren nicht hinterfragen warum muss
sie warum ist die situation noch seit
1981 ist die rettungsflugwacht mitglied
des schweizerischen roten kreuzes in
italien ist der schwer verletzter
patient mittlerweile im ambulanzjet das
flugzeug wird zur intensivstation
ja super widerruf durch mein name ist
heute im moment nicht das paradies
schlucken
ich habe vielleicht noch nicht
[Musik]
der versand kann das unterfangen zum
frieden geschlossen
alles für uns
die jungs gemacht
der diskurs netzwerks grad
[Musik]
eine maschine geschliffen
diese zahlt aus neu vergeben
[Musik]
heimbilanz 7 2
sind sie wir würden gern so schnell wie
möglich landen
[Musik]
landung in der heimat
die ambulanz steht bereit
den schwerverletzten patienten wird die
regler noch ins kantonsspital begleiten
was hier aber noch niemand weiß er wird
seinen verkehrsunfall nicht überleben
[Musik]
breitnau kanton aargau hier lebt yvonne
horisberger hier kommt sie zur ruhe
seit 13 jahren arbeitet die flight neues
für die rege und immer wieder erlebt sie
bei der arbeit schwere momente
sie schaut wichtig dass man dass man
sagt at work abgrenzt und vielleicht ja
bevor man mit crewmitglied ritz beträgt
nach harry potter sie überkommen das
natürlich mit und physisch aber wichtig
dass sie das wirklich verstanden was da
an geld oder die stangen mit dem patent
und das ist heute menschen gestorben im
team über das heck retten und das ist ja
auch nicht schlimm also ich finde dass
wenn man das heute so gut von
rudersberger lied zusammen mit vier
katzen und 19 hasen und kaninchen
ist die flyers in der luft betreuen ihre
wohn partnerin und die nachbarn die
viele tiere
ja ja nicht die verträumt seine pure
hofft aber selbst auch werdegang und
sich gut
man muss man wissen dass gute findet
eben weil man muss es nicht so kommt von
selbst
[Musik]
rega basis bern belp heute ist arzt
tommy von will nicht in wilderswil
sondern hierbei rega drei stationierten
maschinen tommy von biel hat einen
einsatz als instruktor und coach er
beurteilt die abläufe bei reger 3 und
das wissen und können der crew lounge
eck nennen sich dieser regelmäßigen
kontrollen mathias haut liegt mitunter
in den beurteilen
aber man kann medizinische unterstützung
ein notruf aus dem kanton freiburg
[Musik]
und tommy von will findet sich während
des laien checks problemlos zurecht
ausrüstung und abläufe sind auf allen
rega basen gleich
während 33 noch einen landeplatz luft
[Musik]
trifft in der einsatzzentrale schon der
nächste verein aus dem tessin man aber
er ist nicht verletzt
ihr wisst es nicht sie müssen eine winde
einsetzen ok unter wasser aber er ist
nicht allein dort gehst du ihn holen
okay die kunst unterwegs zwischen 2 und
dem sich für werte vor rot und erschöpft
habe sich bewusst sind aber langsam
natürlich immer noch ein weißer ring
inzwischen ist die crew von reger 3 beim
verunglückten wanderer
passanten haben schon erste hilfe
geleistet war unangenehm überrascht als
ich das knacken des knochens hörte ich
denke sie starr knochen gebrochen ist es
waren jedoch legt ihn gut
ich habe meinen gönner beitrag gezahlt
bei diesem helikopter typ dem eurocopter
ec145 steht der rettungssanitäter
während der winter rettung draußen auf
dem sogenannten dpa
sie wollen ihr leben gekommen
prof
[Musik]
dennoch sollte jeder noch nicht mehr
dabei dieser verbraucht
die jungen lieben aufliegen
wann genau
unterwegs
täglich
weiter unten wird der patient in den
helikopter steigen
für den transport ins spital ria zurück
in belp das feedback sind und was mir
sofort aufgefallen ist kommunikation und
richtline oder dass das sei dass mit
ihnen bereit sind von 7 bis profitiert
wonach gefragt ist es ist aber das ist
extrem positiv ausfallen als das erste
mal miteinander zweier mannschaften
haben funktioniert team sind
am flughafen zürich im rega center bis
die stimmung gedämpft
der verunfallte kanu war konnte nicht
gerettet werden
[Musik]
jugendliche auf mein einfluss geht und
wo es brennt rittig und weins sind und
[Musik]
weiter bei reger 3 in welt bis der neuen
check zu ende
der dienst aber noch nicht das dreier
team verbringt 48 stunden am stück auf
der basis
piloten ärzte und rettungssanitäter
leben hier wie in einer wohngemeinschaft
[Musik]
es sind teamplayer gefragt die auch
probleme ansprechen
wichtig ist dass das haupt dass dieser
auch hier bist und winterreisen euro im
team ist visums geräte dürfen wir also
die gesamte haut ich glaube dass
dramatisch und so endlich fit to fly
isolde
an diesem abend ist die volle
einsatzfähigkeit gefragt
[Musik]
heute hatte der koordinator abschicken
es wird eine lange nacht
auch rechner von riga 10 in wilderswil
art pikettdienst er und seine crew
dürfen die nächte aber zu hause
verbringen
im fall einer alarmierung muss er in 30
minuten in der luft sein
[Musik]
pompey
rickmers job verlangt flexibilität auch
von seiner familie
trotzdem ist die arbeit zu hause kein
großes thema thsv vorstellen ohne
bedenkliche probieren sie den wir aus
und doch machen sich die kinder ihre
gedanken
vor dem schlafengehen prüft rick maurer
das wetter und die sicht ist sogar zwei
ag zwischen 9 und 10 zu bett im wissen
dass jederzeit das telefonklingeln
könnte stromstoß fälligkeit zwischen
zwei und vier
eine der heimisch fühlen sich schon
morgen oder risches morgan stanley und
der tut ist dies eigentlich graz
aber das objekt das im auto setzen und
platz fahrer um den schoß und jeder muss
und dass zehn bis 15 mal pro monat hat
rick moy rapide dienst alles liegt
bereit damit er im halbschlaf nichts
vergisst die crew von rega 3 kommt nicht
zur ruhe
sie muss an diesem abend bereits zum
dritten mal ausrücken pilot simon
luginbühl macht sich wegen der gewitter
sorgen welches ist die beste route
es ist kurz vor 2 uhr
bitte mir noch nicht genau was das
bestätigt ein mann ist kollabiert das
ist alles was die rega crew zurzeit weiß
[Musik]
der pilot prüft laufend die wetterlage
inselspital bern oder unispital lausanne
das ist die frage die vor sichtweiten
genau hören und der guide mit taktik
attraktiv dass man aber von westen mit
hinterm qualitäten zufrieden
[Musik]
so ruhig
entweder die krise reagiert worden sei
noch nicht reagiert zu haben
berner inselspital
die rega hat den patienten angemeldet
die spezialisten stehen bereit
[Musik]
und auch nicht fest
anstatt für kupfer ankommen
wahrscheinlich jetzt ganz leicht und ist
offen mit der übergabe des patienten
löst sich bei der rega crew die
anspannung und konzentration und eine
meisterschaft
kathrin becker und licher stadtteil
niemand in dem workshop haben
was hier noch nicht klar ist der patient
wird seinen sturz nicht überleben trotz
aller bemühungen
[Musik]
eine lange nacht geht zu ende nach
diesem einsatz muss die crew von reger
drei mindestens sechs stunden ruhen
[Musik]
will dass wir bei interlaken
rettungssanitäter marco tritt den dienst
an
anders als in bern belp verlief die
nacht ruhig und auch heute morgen bleibt
zeit für die verschiedenen amtlich auf
der basis marco macht hangard trotzt der
mediziner und biologen europa lockt auch
genannt wie genau das macht und das ist
klar mit real aber hier tauschte und da
wurde
und darum setzt so werde das ist schon
super ist also ist der jungspund hat
nicht nur sie zum glück nicht boxer
manny werbefrei
das ist gut die aufwachsen ich
vielleicht einfach nicht meine berufung
[Musik]
negativ erreger verstanden
ja das gibt sich gelassen hat noch
auflegen und zwar hat das geschick durch
cfb und zwar abgestiegen sind jahrgang
zwei flüssigkeiten buch nach einem sturz
die schnell noch verspielt die meldet
das gebäude
[Musik]
heute mit an bord ivo breitenmoser er
ist einer von sieben anästhesisten oder
intensivmedizinern die regelmäßig für
rieger zehn arbeiten
peter sofort spital verlegungen machen
mehr als ein drittel aller rega heli
einsätze aus der transport von kindern
aber ist nie normalität
die kleine ahnung ist beim spielen
bäuchlings auf ein gartentor gestürzt
[Applaus]
die mutter wird im helikopter mit reisen
sondern ich liebe bequeme soll
möglicherweise habe woche für woche vor
der labour vor der milz oder so und
darum geht's in dem spital einfach zu
beachten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einstudiert
[Applaus]
mittendrin
dass bedürftige
verlieben
[Musik]
schon einmal geglaubt
der so genannten schockraum des
inselspitals notaufnahme für
schwerverletzte
mit druckvollem spiel
[Musik]
anouk muss noch einige tage im spital
bleiben
sie wird sich aber gut vom sturz erholen
der rega chat ist wieder unterwegs
richtung süden es ist nicht der erste
einsatz an diesem tag yvonne horisberger
und maße vom dach holen in venedig einen
mann der fast im meer ertrunken ist
[Musik]
schörnig zumal jetzt haben
kunststoffe recht schlucken
[Musik]
die immer bleibt felix 7 mit dem co
piloten bei seiner maschine zurück
ein
geht die kuhn hat feierabend
vor ihr liegt eine mehr als einstündige
heimfahrt ins glarnerland
schweigend saßen sie eine zeitlang
beisammen stadtbahn ging zur tür also
wer sich auf den heimweg machen doch
noch ins auto setzen und dann geht's los
radio und sie vergeben haben sehr
schnell in denen die geschichten und mit
einer unser geschäft und fahren aber
diese der heimat erreichte die stanzen
als könne jetzt wieder an spürte sagte
er
heirate mich ich liebe dich ich werde
mein lieber darauf verwenden dich
glücklich zu machen
[Applaus]
die crew des ambulanzjets ist inzwischen
in einem ambulanz boot unterwegs
seit tagen
[Musik]
ja genau der richtige
ankunft beim spital
[Musik]
hast du dann auf see
ja stimmen und ist er senior herburg
wurden als elisabeth kurze woche dr vom
dach freut mich sie zu lachen aber so
wie mit schuhen von atemnot das hat sie
nötig das richtig gut seoul würde unter
fünf prozent ist das gut
mit ihrer frau ich sehe schwarz wurde
von der au getan bohlens studio hören
sie mal lud die jungen stufe und um
stufe
auf druck sieht der foto logan bailly
das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm das ist
völlig normal
das ist noch gelungen entzündet dass der
controller hat sie keinen zünder
das ist mir sehr gut sehr gute nachricht
ist das wirklich so
das super
lutz dazu verfahren missbrauch aus
infusion standen sondern mit der
hofstelle wie ich sie so ok
[Musik]
willi brachat locken
ihr marktwert weiter zu lassen wir sind
jetzt gerade abfahren vom spital
das kultur mit dem hobby was man alles
machen darf
ich würde mich würde mal sagen so jetzt
musste er feststellen dass es
automatisch rückfahrt auf dem canal
grande
für die letzte etappe geht es vom boot
wieder auf die straße
am flughafen wartet die crew aber
vergeblich sie hat an diesem tag schon
mehrere einsätze hinter sich philipp
sémon wird unruhig von gesetzeswegen
darf er nicht länger als zwölf stunden
am stück arbeiten dieser zeit droht
abzulaufen
der träger übernehmen
sehr gut und man sie braucht
endlich treffen patient und crew ein
das ambulanzfahrzeug war auf umwegen
unterwegs die fahrt dauerte eine stunde
statt 15 minuten
allen ist klar kann der jet nicht bald
abheben müsste im cockpit eine neue crew
übernehmen
jetzt war es handy in der hand mit navi
aber ich glaube er wurde wie lieb 7
eine gerade zeitnot und die 50 minuten
die medizinische crew hat den
zeitrückstand wettgemacht philipp sémon
kann die mission zu ende bringen einen
von mehr als 1200 jet einsetzen der rega
pro jahr
[Musik]
will dass wir am nächsten morgen und was
er aß und was hätte radio drs ok also
ein zimmer ab und das ist nördlich und
westlich von nadja i sultan ii
ok also frau irgendwo dazwischen
wanderweg wovon grad links aber ich war
ja eher selten selber sieht glos
gesprochen
tommy und michael empfang hätte
eigentlich seine frau gehört und ist
jetzt aber im sande strand alarmiert
aber jetzt liegt die frau da irgendwo im
wagen
[Musik]
durch die durch ein richtungstor
durchschritten naja ob das paket die uns
geht das wirklich gemein
[Applaus]
im rollstuhl
art tommy von will macht sich zu fuß auf
die suche nach der verunfallten frau
derweil geht romeo tango in
warteposition
und schon bald hat tommy von wien seine
patientin gefunden ist
jetzt bin ich ja für mich
danach entspanne ja
christlich liberalen
start zur wilden rettung ein heikler
einsatz
[Applaus]
vor allem wenn man da viel spaß dass sie
das nicht viele nächte reef liegt
praktisch das jahr vorbei und die sonne
nicht gefahr dass das pflegeheim in den
relativ gut aus
[Musik]
gut so
ja das muss
carolina
auch gepackt zu haben
der frosch und ist gold
[Musik]
ausgeschafft worden
so stieg
[Musik]
doch auch menschlich zu kochen
locker durch
[Musik]
im laufe des morgens fortgerissen
die patientin hat das bein mehrfach
gebrochen der heilungsprozess wird
monate dauern
rettung um rettung unfälle krankheiten
schicksale
diese erlebnisse hallen im privatleben
der rega crew noch danke dass ich darin
fragt das modebewusste und vielleicht
ein problem so ein stimmt weil man wahre
problem kennt
[Musik]
china präsentiert wurde woanders